the thing i love most about being a
mother is seeing an incredible human
that i played a role in molding and just
giving her the tools to be her best most
authentic self
my name is cheyenne rogers and i am 26
years old i am in hartford connecticut
at uconn school of law and i am in my 1l
studying to be a lawyer
[Music]
i was born to two drug addicted parents
in san pedro california
and
they lost custody of me and my siblings
shortly after my first birthday from
there we kind of bounced around a bit
from foster home to foster home in l.a
county and then i was eventually adopted
when i was six everything was fine
initially but progressively
the home just got more abusive
physically emotionally and mentally and
i eventually left at 13.
i was homeless for about a year and i
re-entered foster care and i was placed
in a group home in south central and
then when i got pregnant i was placed in
another group home by macarthur park
near echo park in la
when i got pregnant with layla it just
really encouraged me to stabilize and go
back to school and focus on her future i
needed to do good in order for her to do
good
i lived through foster care and it would
have been incredible to have had someone
that looked like me that lived life like
me and was in foster care representing
me and that's why i want to become an
attorney
i think i've always known that i wanted
to be an attorney they had so much
control over what happened to my life i
also just so i felt like i had a knack
for arguing and being an advocate and
being a lawyer is just like the next
step up for me
[Music]
i hope to eventually work with foster
youth in some capacity either
on an individual level or on a policy
level i want to end the
intergenerational cycle of foster care i
don't want my daughter to ever enter
foster care or have to experience the
child welfare system in any capacity
my daughter layla is 10 years old she's
so sassy and brave and beautiful
i get to relive my childhood through her
a better more wholesome version of what
my childhood should have been
she always feels safe she always feels
loved she always feels like there's food
in the fridge for her and knowing that
she gets to be her truest self without
fear without survival instinct just
being at the forefront
i moved out here
beginning of august and i cross country
road tripped it with my daughter and a
friend of mine so it took us about nine
days to get here
the program is three years and i will
graduate in 2024
and when i do i will have my jd my juris
doctor degree
and after i pass the bar i will be able
to say that i am cheyenne rogers esquire
hearing cheyenne rogers esquire anywhere
near my name is really kind of
mind-blowing i i never thought
i would actually get to this point so
i'm i'm excited
i think with law school
everyone's really stressed out but being
from a background where
no one
graduated college or pursued graduate
school there's this added layer of
feeling
not good enough and there's this very
real imposter syndrome
financially it's really expensive to go
to grad school
or law school i've really relied on
scholarships and financial aid to get
here
even the financial burden is just one
part of it there's also the success of
even being here only three to four
percent of foster youth will even
graduate college and the number does not
exist for graduate studies so i feel
very much like i'm exploring unknown
territory here
[Music]
hi shane how you doing i'm good how are
you
i am doing great this is so exciting
because i heard your story and i'm so
wild about all of it my mentors are choa
and i am a content creator at buzzfeed
tasty thank you for sharing your story
and your experiences with us since
you're working so hard to make a
difference we want to give you a little
something to help you out throughout
your journey zell is sending you three
thousand dollars oh my gosh you can
continue all the amazing work you're
doing uh and thanks to zell you will
have the money in a few minutes oh my
god didn't wear my waterproof mascara
we really hope you enjoyed this gift
from zell and best of luck
i'm just really blown away this
opportunity was incredible uh and i'm so
happy that
buzzfeed and zell got together and
thought that i was worthy to be selected
for this so i'm just extremely grateful
thank you so much zell i really
appreciate it